Speaker 1: Donald trump claims he will be arrested
tomorrow. Will he? I don't know. Is Trump lying?
Maybe. Is Trump confused? Possibly. Often is
the case, but if Trump is indicted. If Trump is
arrested, what will be the reaction from magazine?
Well, here are the five reactions I expect. Number
one, we've already seen this one. Investigators
already resigned because there was no case. So
you know that this case is bogus. Wrong didn't
happen. We covered this at the time. The truth
is that investigators resigned because they came
to believe, even though we are finding evidence
against Trump, we don't believe there is any real
willingness to indict him. So we're wasting our
time. The right wingers are defending Trump by
saying investigators resigned because there was
no evidence. The truth is, investigators resigned
because there was evidence, but they thought it
was all for nothing because nobody would actually
indict Trump. If Trump is indicted, they will have
been wrong. But it is a lie that is being told.
That's reaction number one. The investigators
already decided there was no case. No, they did
not. Number two, and they're already saying this.
The focus really should be on Hunter Biden. And
there's a few different versions of this defense.
One is they are arresting Trump to distract
from Hunter Biden. Makes no sense whatsoever.
The legal bodies that are investigating Hunter
Biden are not are are not necessarily the ones
that would be indicting Trump or arresting Trump.
Complete fabrication, No evidence whatsoever.
Response number three from the magazine. Democrats
are doing this because Trump is surging against
Biden in the 2024 polls are wrong. We actually
need only look at the polling to figure this out.
And consistently, Ron DeSantis is stronger
against Biden than is Trump. So the facts
conflict. We have a new Emerson College poll,
highly rated pollster, which says Biden is losing
to De Santos but leading Trump. Well, that doesn't
really go with what Trump is claiming. We have a
we have a Quinnipiac University poll which finds
that Biden leads DeSantis by only one but leads
Trump by four. So this is another claim that
they are making. Democrats are doing this because
Trump is getting so strong in the polling, they
need to do something to hurt him. No, in fact,
it is the Santos who is stronger in the polling.
Number four, they will say, and they already did
this over the weekend on Newsmax and elsewhere.
This is evidence of the two tiered justice system,
One system of justice for Republicans and one
system of justice for Democrats are wrong. There
is a two tiered justice system, but it is that
for the rich who can negotiate their surrenders
without having to be handcuffed and all these
things and then everybody else, We have a two
tiered justice system, but it is not Republicans
and Democrats. And then lastly, number five
defense is these charges related to the Stormy
Daniels hush money are very, very weak. I actually
agree with that defense. My hope is, as I said in
the last segment, that this is just the beginning
and that the levy will break with these charges
if indeed they are coming. We don't know that for
sure. And that then other prosecutors federally,
maybe in Georgia, which I believe is actually the
strongest case in Georgia, other charges will
come forward and that this will only be the
beginning. But I agree actually with the magazine,
the Stormy Daniels situation is not the strongest
set of facts for an arrest and indictment against
Donald Trump. So those are the five defenses that
I expect, many of which inversions we are already
seeing. Let's take a quick break. And after the
break, we will talk about some of the other
aspects of this. They're talking about George
Soros or I should say, George Soros, as they often
I don't know why the people who really don't like
George Soros seem unable to say his last name
correctly and so many other things. Stay with
us. On what could be the eve of an historic
day of a historic day of both potentially on
The David Pakman Show YouTube.com slash The David
Pakman Show. Make sure you're subscribed, folks.